and you know what the great thing about
sports is over music it's really the
only meritocracy yeah right like yes
music we can all sit here and go okay
there are certain rhythms that are nice
to hear no matter what type of human
being you are you enjoy them yeah but
you could still go on that into jazz or
I'm not into rock around that into rap
yeah you can't say the team didn't beat
the other team yeah you can't say at the
end of the day he didn't score more
points then that other guy most simple
it's conquest it is at its most simplest
form it's war without casualties without
death without anything weighing on my
conscience I just watched the most
primal thing you can watch so that you
know so you know the greatness is
quality yeah you can't qualify musical
greatness we could sit here go jay-z's
the greatest rapper ever there's
somebody who there's somebody out there
who does not like the way jay-z raps you
can actually specifically quantify their
greatness you kick exactly as actual
numbers without a doubt this team is
greater it's like even with and I
obviously I want to put stand-up out
there right
even with stand-up you can make a
decision to not laugh you can not laugh
if you choose to Nala interview things
everybody you can not laugh yeah you
can't not see someone wind yeah they
just win or they don't
so his greatness is undeniable
he was greatness if he was great at
something that is merit-based only that
is greatness in his truth form gladiator
[ __ ] low-key one thing I thought economy
during the doc how I think multiple
times when people are talking about him
they were like oh yeah he's like the
closest thing to God Larry Bird Lykos
how do people just say that casually
said Larry Bird at the height of Larry
Bird said this highlight of Larry Bird
from Indiana Christian Indiana oh yes
well okay I wasn't watching Michael
Jordan out there
I was watching God
skies disguise yeah that's as him crazy
like even the most genius people today
just compare themselves to other
geniuses nobody says oh I'm on God level
yeah like nobody's like Jordan was the
only person people spoke about like that
son it sounds true it's so true imagine
just being so unrelatable imagine seeing
a talent so unrelatable that you have to
relate it to God you know how like when
we can't explain something yeah right
we just relate it to the most advanced
piece of technology we have right right
so we can't really explain how our
brains work yeah right so we usually
relate it to a computer exact computer
and there was a time before computer
where we related to a calculator a
calculator and then before a calculator
it's who knows what the [ __ ] it is a
company I don't know whatever the best
[ __ ] you got an engine yeah for a runner
it would say it was like an engine for a
car your brain is like the engine to a
car like into the okay yeah right but
you're you're relating it to things that
exist mmm the kreisau skill that was so
amazing and he goes there's nothing on
the planet I can relate this to us there
are no other athletes I can relate this
to there are no other animals you can't
even go he would like when you see an
eagle soar that's sort of know God yeah
it's God and I that height that's still
my favorite Jordan highlight is that
game the through the legs twice and then
finish it's just like so casual pop-up
so fast and then he finishes I don't
know a lot Birds dee was good he stayed
hot him but he's just against a force
that is greater there's nothing you
could do is physics and that's my god yo
he's gone you can't it's an act of God
but I just saw was an act of God I can't
compete with this I just don't
understand how he was so well-adjusted
man I mean maybe he wasn't because he
did have the gambling and the drinking
that kind of stuff and like the
excessive you know competitive outlets
with golf and ping pong and these types
of things but like he seems so calm
every time you saw him an interview he
didn't seem rattled they didn't seem
comfortable he is the biggest human on
the earth
in that point in time and he's unfazed
by it it just seems that he's a he can't
wait for competition he's not going oh
my god I got all this - all these are
these people weighing on me all these
people hoping that I win a competition
is probably the break from all that I
mean that is greatness right there you
can't wait for that final moment because
it's just I mean it's also like if I've
been doing nothing but [ __ ] business
decisions and everybody's in my face all
the time this is my sanctuary there's
ninety four five a lot of you dude
I get that now like people ask me like
if I'm nervous to go on stage before
show sometimes the busier I am and the
more [ __ ] up [ __ ] I got going on my
life I can't wait to be on stage yeah
cuz I know that be on stage requires
such a singular focus I can't think
about any of it I get to leave it all
behind
there ain't even room for ya
[Applause]